الرمال في كل مكان هنا في منطقه يارجل
الولايات الشماليه في السودان على بعد
نحوي
4050 كلم عن العاصمه الخرطوم بل ان الرمال
اخرجت سليمان واسرته من منزلهم
صار المنزل كمان منطقه ساحه تتقاسمها
الرمال والرياح
والصمت احيانا ولم يكن بمقدور سليمان
واسرته سوى هجر الديار
البيت ده بيتنا ومن 398
في هذه المناطق التي كانت تنبض بالشعر
والحياه في قريه ارجيله شرق الدبه ساد
تاكل
وهجر كثير من الناس ربوعهم في صمت انه
التصحر على مد البصر
من عوامل هذا التصحري القطع الجائر
للاشجار والرعي غير المنظم وقله المياه
الجوفيه القريبه من سطح الارض
[موسيقى]
لا اشارات مرور هنا سوى ان الزحف
الصحراويه يمنع العبور او لا يسهله في
احسن الاحوال
كانت هذه طرق حركه اقتصاديه تجاريه بين
مدينه دنجلا حاضره الولايه الشماليه
ومناطق اخرى
قد يحلم الاهالي بتدفق المياه لكنهم
يحصلون على شلالات الرمال
سنويا في ولايه تبلغ مساحتها
350 كلم مربع
وبعد فتره بسيطه
الى قريه العقال التي تبعدون نحو الثلاثين
كيلو متر جنوب مدينه دنقله ارتسمت شواهد
الخطا كثبان الرملي تهدد القريه واهلها
بالحصار بل وتهدد نهر النيل وقد تتحدى
الجهود الرسميه في مكافحه التصحر
وزعنا لحد الان 40 الف شكله واستهدفنا
حواليه 35 مزارع وبعدين اللون نوزع اللون
الاحزمه شجريه
لمنع الزحف الصحراوي وللتوسع في زراعه
وزياده الرقعه الزراعيه
كلوحه فنيه الا انه يمثل لاهل هذه الربوع
شبحا يهدد حياتهم واستقرارهم
تزحف الرمال على هذه القريه كما زحفت على
قرى اخرى قبلها وبات مشهد التصحر مبعث قلق
للناس لما يحمله من خطر
يهدد مظاهر الحياه الطاهره المرضي الجزيره
من الولايات الشماليه العقال